now thank you
good afternoon
i'd like to start by thanking chancellor
schultz for
making his visit to washington
we had an opportunity to have a very
productive meeting
i think our staffs wondered whether
we're going to let them in at all
we spent the first half hour more
talking together and uh
and it's been a very very useful meeting
one of the things that struck me was the
shared values
and uh that shape how each of us
approaches leadership
among them the foundational commitment
to the dignity of workers
and the need to treat all people with
respect
so i enjoyed speaking with you all off
and i know uh working together will
continue to strengthen and deepen our
alliance
and the extensive partnership between
germany and the united states
of course at the top of our agenda today
was our united approach
to deterring russia's threats against
ukraine
and the long-standing principles of
rule-based international order that's
what we spent most of our time talking
about
german in the united states together
with our allies and partners
are working closely together to pursue
diplomatic resolutions in this situation
and diplomacy is the very best way
forward for all sides we both agree
including best for russia in our view
and we have made it very clear we're
ready to continue talks in good faith
with russia
germany has also been a leader in
pushing de-escalation of tensions and
encouraging dialogue
through the normandy format
but if russia makes a choice to further
invade ukraine we are jointly ready and
all of nato is ready
today the chancellor and i discussed our
close cooperation
develop strong past package of sanctions
that are going to clearly demonstrate
international resolve and impose swift
and severe consequences if russia
violates ukraine's sovereignty and its
territorial integrity
and i want to thank germany and uh and
all of our other partners in eastern
europe in the european union for their
work in this united effort
we are in agreement that it cannot be
business as usual if russia further
invades
we also discussed our shared commitment
to nato's article 5 responsibilities
and reassurance of our eastern flank
allies we're united in that as well
already the united states is sending
troops to reinforce the alliance
and i want to thank the chancellor of
germany for hosting additional u.s
forces
and for the long-standing hospitality to
our women and men in uniform
we also discussed the challenges we're
facing to the international order from
china
along with russia and other competitors
that are pursuing more illiberal futures
we've agreed that germany united states
will continue to work together
to ensure that the rules and principles
governing emerging technologies
are geared to advance freedom of
opportunity not repression or
authoritarianism
we also reaffirmed our commitment to
completing the work of integrating the
western balkans into the european
institutions and to finally realize a
europe that is whole
free and at peace
with germany holding the presidency of
the g7
we also talked about how that form can
harness the world's leading democracies
to advance a robust agenda of global on
global challenges from ending the
pandemic to addressing climate change
so the bottom line is this
whether as allies and nato
partners through the european union
as leaders of the g7 to g20 or through
our strong bilateral relationship german
and united states are close friends
and reliable partners and we can count
on one another
there is no issue of global importance
where germany and the united states are
not working together
strength to strength and applying and
amplifying our efforts together
so i want to thank you all all for
making the journey today and i look
forward to being the first of many
opportunities we can spend together
beginning this meeting and uh throughout
the rest of the year and the university
of our terms so thank you welcome
floor
much detail today and that i was able to
make my first official visit here and
that we also could talk about the
important questions that we're dealing
with today we are in a very difficult
situation
and it is a
good thing that joe and i were able to
discuss what we need to do in this
difficult context of course there is a
military threat in ukraine
against ukraine now we cannot remain
silent on that we see the number of
russian troops along the ukrainian
border
and that is a
it is important that all allies the us
and
germany concert landscape partnership
between the uh
[Music]
this is a very clear message everybody
if
at the same time it is important to use
all diplomatic means we have and i'm
very glad
great willingness to
move forward together especially the
bilateral talks between the us and
russia
and of course the talks that we have
agreed upon within the nato russia
format this is also important
also because russia needs to understand
that nato stands together and that nato
is prepared after
so many years there have not been any
talks in this format so it is a good
sign that they are happening now
of course we have controversy based
there but it is important that we talk
and the same is true for the osce
well we need to discuss about security
in europe this is also a progress as
tiresome as it may be
we have not yet reached any very
substantial uh conclusions yet but it is
good to see that this format plays a
role now and the same is true for the
thoughts between ukraine russia france
and germany the normandy format
but we haven't been able to really
use it in a productive way over the last
few years so now we have come back to
that format we are having tough
discussions in that format and that
shows that there are ways that we'll use
out of this difficult situation and this
dual track approach of clear
announcements with regard to sanctions
that will be taken if there is a
military aggression and at the same time
keeping all dialogue
open i think this is the most promising
strategy one can have and that is what
we're doing together and we stand side
by side in this approach we also talked
about many other topics that are
important for us today especially when
it comes to the g7 presidency of the
federal republic of germany
we will work closely as strong economies
strong democracies
we also therefore have a special mandate
to contribute to
cohesion worldwide and part of this is
that we continue to do everything we can
to make sure that the citizens of the
world can be vaccinated not only in our
rich countries
but also in countries
where people would love to have the
vaccine but don't have access yet
and these are initiatives that we have
carried out together and that are of
importance worldwide
the same is true for fighting
man-made climate change a big topic that
keeps us all busy even though it is
obvious that only a global solution can
be successful because climate is a
global thing it doesn't stop at national
borders
as an industrialized nations we have an
important contribution to make we have
technological opportunities economic
opportunities and have to use them in
order to prepare a situation where we
and others can enjoy prosperity without
harming the climate this is the big
challenge
that we see
and that is of great importance to us so
this is why we want to work together on
this strategy and use a climate club of
like-minded people
and their partners
these are some of the topics we
discussed and once again the
personal discussion we had
illustrates the excellent cooperation
between our countries the strong bond we
have within our transatlantic
partnership and the fact that both
countries can rely on each other
well thank you very much well i'll take
a
couple questions each uh
reuters and
andrea
you got the first question thank you mr
president and uh thank you chancellor
schultz um mr president
i have wanted to ask you about this um
nordstrom project that you've long
opposed you didn't mention it just now
by name nor did champ search holes did
you receive assurances
from chancellor schultz today that
germany will in fact pull the plug on
this project
uh if russia invades ukraine and did you
discuss what the definition of invasion
could be
and then chancellor schwartz uh
um
to not support the swift measures
let me answer the first question first
if germany
if uh if russia invades uh that means
tanks or troops crossing the uh the
border of ukraine again then uh
there will be uh we there will be no
longer a norse team too we we will bring
an end to it
how would you how will you do that
exactly
since the project in control of the
project is within germany's control
we will uh
i promise you we'll be able to do it
thank you very much for your question i
want to be absolutely clear we have
intensively prepared everything to be
ready with the necessary sanctions if
there is a
military aggression against ukraine
and this is necessary it is necessary
that we do this in advance so that
russia can clearly understand that these
are far-reaching severe measures
it is part of the
this process that we do not spell out
everything in public because russia
could understand that there might be
even more to come
and at the same time it is very clear we
are well prepared for far-reaching
measures we will take these measures
together with our allies
with our partners with the us
and we will take all necessary steps you
can be sure that there won't be any
measures
in which we
have a different approach we will act
together jointly this is a good idea to
say to our american friends we will be
united we will act together and we will
take all the necessary steps and all the
necessary steps will be done by all of
us together
will you commit today to turning off and
pulling the plug on nordstrom too you
didn't mention it you haven't mentioned
it
as i already said we are acting together
we are absolutely united and we will not
taking different steps we will do the
same steps and they will be very very
hard to russia and they should
understand
you recognize someone now chancellor
fisher
yep
mr president one question to you the u.s
over the last few
years heavy weapons to ukraine and
germany
excludes that has only delivered 5 000
helmets
to ukraine don't you think that nato
should act unanimously in this respect
and germany as the strongest european
nato partner
should also deliver heavy weapons to
ukraine
uh and ukraine has asked germany to do
so and on north stream too i would also
like to ask don't you think with regard
to the threat by russia germany should
already
think it's position or not stream too
and the third question if i may
over the last few days and weeks there
has been severe criticism
from the u.s media and from congress as
well visiting germany about the
reliability of germany as an ally this
has been called into question
do you understand this criticism is
germany a reliable partner
from your point of view and mr
chancellor also a question to you
nordstrom 2
you said all options are on the table
as a strong ally here for the us
there's no need to win back trust he has
the complete trust of the united states
germany
is one of our most important allies in
the world there is no doubt about
germany's partnership with the united
states none
with regard to
helping ukraine one of the largest
contributors financially to ukraine has
been germany
germany has been in the forefront of
making sure providing economic
assistance
you also asked the question yes so many
i can't remember them all
but uh
in terms of
the u.s media saying germany is not
reliable germany's completely reliable
completely totally thoroughly reliable i
have no doubt about germany at all
one of
and it will be relevant in the future as
well just as relevant and this will be
one of our top priorities always
on behalf of nato we are
a country
[Music]
that
since 2014 about 2 billion u.s
direct dollars support and within the eu
an additional 3.8 billion
that is made available so substantial
financial means to stabilize the
ukrainian economy and we are willing to
continue with that
between our two countries part of this
is that with regard to the difficult
situation at the ukrainian border
due to the russian troops we have made
it very clear
we will unanimously act in terms of
sanctions mr president once again uh a
question with regards to arms exports do
you think it is okay that nato partners
have different approaches
of germany with regard to the russian
threat is okay
look
there is
no doubt in america's mind
that germany
is an incredibly reliable ally
and one of the leading physical powers
in
nato number one
number two
the notion that
nordstrom t would go north stream two
would go forward
with an invasion by the russians it's
just not going to happen
now
wall street journal sabrina
thank you mr president based on
everything you know now do you think
that president putin will authorize an
invasion of ukraine before the end of
the winter and what is your message to
the roughly 30 000 americans who are
currently in ukraine do you think that
they should leave the country
well i've
had discussions numerous discussions
with uh
with
the russians and particularly with
people
i don't know that he's even made him i
don't know that he knows what he's going
to do
and
i think he has to realize that it would
be a
gigantic mistake for him to move
on ukraine the impact on europe and the
rest of the world would be devastating
and he would pay a heavy price
i have been very very straightforward
and blunt with
president putin both on the phone and in
person
we will impose the most severe sanctions
that have ever been imposed economic
sanctions
and there will be a lot to pay for that
down the road it will affect others as
well it will affect us somewhat affect
europeans but it will have profound
impact on his economy and uh i
i but i don't know i know that he's in a
position now to be able to invade almost
uh assuming that uh um the uh the ground
is frozen above kiev
uh he has the capacity to do that what
he's going to do i don't know
and uh i don't think anybody knows but
him
to the americans who are currently in
ukraine should they leave the country i
think it'd be wise to leave the country
uh not i don't mean our i don't mean i'm
not talking about our diplomatic corps
i'm talking about americans who are
there i hate to see them get caught in a
crossfire if in fact they did admit and
there's no need for that and i if i were
they if i had anyone there i'd say leave
to chancellor schultz can you outline
specific steps that germany is taking to
reduce its energy dependence on russia
and what do you say to those who suggest
that german reliance on russian gas is
limiting europe's options for how to
respond to the crisis in ukraine
raising that question because it gives
me the opportunity to address and topic
that's important to me one good uh news
maybe
within its strategy on fighting man-made
climate change germany has decided as
very short uh in a very short
period of time to phase out of the use
of oil
very soon and by 2045 germany will have
a carbon carbon-neutral economy as one
of the strongest economies of the world
and
with regard to these
energies we often think about eating at
home and driving our carpet we're
talking about industrial production
producing steel
and chemical
cement and changing these industrial
processes and reorganizing such systems
is what we have planned so this year we
will continue to take far-reaching
decisions that will help us
to
use more wind energy offshore wind
energy onshore wind energy and solar
energy
and expand the capacities expand the
grids
and
have strategy for germany but also
worldwide on the use of hydrogen which
is a central element for us to change
our industrial processes that are using
oil and gas right now
the industry is willing to be on board
we're doing this together with them but
it will probably be the biggest
industrial modernization project in
germany in 100 years
with very good prospects that we will
develop new technologies that other
partners in the world can use as well
and this will help us fight climate
change
and by the way at the energy mix today
we are talking about one quarter of our
energy that is linked to gas
and only part of that gas comes from
russia a big park comes from norway or
the netherlands
and of course it is very important to us
that we
develop an infrastructure that will give
us the opportunity to
have all options available and react if
needed so you don't have to be concerned
there are some who should be concerned
who see themselves maybe too much as a
deliverer of such resources
because
we are focusing on renewable energies we
will go down that path
and make sure that this is the
uh profitable future
i would like to ask you a question about
lng germany and europe
are much more dependent on russian gas
than other regions of the world
and you
promised european allies to help with
lng
but
this resource is more expensive it's not
available in the volumes that might be
needed to replace russian gas and i
would like to know from you how you
would help europeans in case of a
conflict with russia is this an empty
promise or what can you really do
what can
package against russia
and mr chancellor
liquefied natural gas um there is a big
controversy in germany about um cracking
gas and how far is lng even a real
replacement or is it
also with a view to the climate club you
intend to found is it really an
alternative to russian pipeline gas
well let me respond
first of all we are looking at
opportunities to
make up for
lost
gas lng from
russia
we're on their way of trying to see what
we can do to do that
dealing with our friends around the
world as well we think we could make up
a significant portion of it
that would be lost but what everybody
forgets here
is
russia
needs to be able to sell that gas and
sell that oil
russia relies a significant part of
russia's budget it's the only thing they
really have to export
and if in fact it's cut off then they're
going to be hurt very badly as well
and there's some consequence to them as
well this is not just a one-way street
and so
we are looking at what we could do to
help compensate for a loss of immediate
loss of gas
in europe if it occurs
and
that's what we've been working on for
some time now
and joe biden and i are working closely
together as well
we are prepared for all kinds of
situation and that's part of
what we do when we say we prepare
sanctions
that means we need to be able to
to react at any time and this is
happening
with regard to the use of lng i can say
that
the biggest volume of lng used across
the world is their gas
that is part of the debate
concerning a long term perspective i
already outlined what this is about we
will
modernize our economy until gas is being
used we will switch to hydrogen
this will be a process that will be
fast will happen faster than many might
imagine today and that will create a
bright future for all of us
thank you
thank you very much
appreciate it
yes
yes
my
foreign
you